I'm gonna show you what we came up with
but this isn't necessarily the right
answer remember this is an art it's not
a science and either way I'm not going
to give you the whole answer I'm leaving
a few tweaks for you to make and you'll
be working on this side again at the end
of the next lesson looking at the new
site there are a number of major changes
let's go ahead and start small first off
the nav buttons that were right here
above the hero
I've been shifted off canvas into the
hamburger button menu the hamburger
button is the one with the three
horizontal lines and now we've got our
nav links over here on the side this is
a nice way of retrieving a little bit of
screen real estate also the header text
is a little bit smaller to match this
smaller viewport the first breakpoint
comes in at 550 pixels see how the
elements reef load and change their
location on the screen the weather is
now here in this second position the
hero is only taking up about 60% of the
viewport width well the weather has the
other 40% also the nav button showed
back up to see how it's done I've opened
up sublime text you can see some
breakpoints like this one using
min-width 550 pixels and this one using
mid width 700 pixels and these
breakpoints include changes to order and
widths of different elements on the
screen like hero and weather breakpoints
like these make it really easy to change
the width and order of elements and
totally change and shift the layout the
next breakpoint comes in at 700 pixels
across the layouts changed a bit
top news has moved up here and we've got
50% on the top news side and 50% for the
hero image and the weather is now down
below add even larger widths eventually
the main section of the page keeps to a
fixed width this was accomplished with a
breakpoint that set the width to 850
pixels once the pages viewport is as
large or larger than 850 pixels
I've also shifted the scores and the
weather the scores are taking up 60% of
the screen and the weather's got 40% the
design that you saw here takes advantage
of a mostly fluid design
with a little bit of layout shifting I
think the hometown side is actually
looking pretty good right now but it's
definitely not perfect let's look at the
weather real quick on this view the
weather looks like so with this cute
little icon right here and then the
actual temperature right next to it but
if you resize the screen just a little
bit the temperature drops down to the
line below it and that's actually kind
of gross I don't like that I also think
that something better could be done with
the hero image watch the edge of it as a
screen resizes see how the edge actually
changes that's because right now CSS is
being used to set and position the image
background size cover will scale up the
image to make sure it covers the entire
div I think there could be a better
solution what do you think in the next
lesson you'll get a chance to finish the
site and make even more improvements